o Olá eu sou aluna egressa da usb-c me
formei no ano passado engenharia
ambiental e Urbana e atualmente o Sou
aluna do programa de pós-graduação em
Ciência e Tecnologia ambiental também
não fbc e eu mantenho um blog eu
cientista também a gente bom eu queria
começar a minha palestra com a seguinte
pergunta o que é uma mulher para fazer
ciência eu me perguntei isso por muito
tempo porque pessoalmente como mulher eu
nunca de fato sentir que eu tinha o
perfil para ser cientista então sempre
me pergunta aí como eu deveria me
importar o que que eu deveria falar
quando que deveria dizer sim quanto que
deveria dizer não era sempre uma atenção
então
o casamento isso é uma coisa muito comum
entre as mulheres cientistas que
observei na minha convivência e eu
observei também que era algo bem menos
comum para os homens é quase como se ele
já soubessem o que fazer eles se
sentirão em casa à vontade e eu sei que
isso é um sentimento comum em vários
espaços mas por alguma razão eu acho que
ela aqui na ciência seja diferente
talvez porque eu tinha essa ideia da
ciência como sendo totalmente objetiva e
Imparcial totalmente dissociada das
questões individuais e no caso das
questões de gênero mas a gente sabe que
não é bem assim e eu acho que eu
descobri isso talvez de uma forma não
tão bacana bom a ordem social vigente
ela naturalmente vai reverberar em todo
o espaço social então o mês científico
assim como qualquer outro meio também
tem suas ir Arquias suas dinâmicas
sociais que são os mesmos dinâmicas de
modo geral
a nossa sociedade e o que que é essa
dinâmica basicamente né bom a gente tem
homens ocupando cadeiras de liderança
posições de decisão uma estrela
legendado geralmente e é interessante
observar que a figura do cientista ela
foi construída em torno da figura
masculina então a gente pode reparar que
quando alguém cita a palavra cientista a
primeira coisa que a gente pensa é no
homem geralmente um homem de cabelos
brancos com jaleco tubo de ensaio isso é
tão verdade essa noção da figura
masculina como sendo o cientista que por
exemplo quando a gente vai citar um
trabalho e não conhece o primeiro nome
do autor ou da autora automaticamente
presumimos que é um homem nos referimos
ao autor daquele trabalho como um homem
esses homens nas ciências geralmente são
muito admirados não que não existam
também mulheres admiradas na ciência
claro que existem mas esse protagonismo
geralmente fica com os homens
bom então eu quis entender um pouco mais
essa relação da mulher com a ciência
então eu decidi perguntar para pessoas
comuns qual que era a visão de mulher
que as pessoas tinham não qualquer
mulher deveria ser uma mulher que que
tivesse um perfil que essas pessoas
consideravam admirável então com a ajuda
da equipe do Tex também de alguns amigos
nós reunimos 48 pessoas e a cada uma
dessas pessoas Foi pedido que você tá
sem cinco adjetivos positivos sobre a
uma mulher que as pessoas admirassem
eles eles elas não precisavam falar quem
era a mulher então era só citar os cinco
adjetivos mesmo os primeiros que viessem
a mente essas pessoas foram selecionadas
totalmente aleatoriamente não é uma
pessoa sal do meu círculo também havia
uma diversidade de idade de contexto de
escolaridade escrevi tá quê que a
pesquisa mesmo sendo uma pesquisa
simples ficar sem mesada então com essa
pesquisa
a montar duas nuvens de palavras e aí a
primeira delas vocês podem enviar a
nuvem de mulheres foram as palavras mais
citadas pelas mulheres a gente consegue
ver forte determinada inteligente
resiliente e amorosa Essas foram as
cinco palavras mais citadas entre as
mulheres prestem bastante atenção nelas
agora vamos ver a nuvem de palavras
criadas com as palavras citadas pelos
homens bom assim com mais citadas foram
nessa ordem inteligente dedicada em
prática organizada e amorosa bom Agora
eu quero que a gente pensa um pouco
sobre essas palavras de o que elas
representam gente porque que uma mulher
admirável é justamente aquela que cuida
que ama e sobretudo aquela que é forte
resiliente isso é muito importante então
facilmente a gente consegue fazer aí uma
conexão
e social da mulher que foi construído e
mantido ao longo do tempo que é esse
papel de dedicação ao lar e aos filhos
ao marido a gestão emocional de modo
geral a gestão do Lar também exige que a
mulher seja inteligente que ela de conta
de tudo que ela se apresente bem
entretêm os amigos os familiares enfim E
por que forte porque dedicada bom a
gente precisa tentar muito a gente
sempre precisa tentar muito são muitas
negativas no meio do caminho e daí vem
essa resiliência porque a cada duas
portas que se fecham para uma mulher
gente duas portas se abrem para um homem
a gente tem que ter quatro vezes melhor
em tudo é cansativo não é uma fortaleza
porque gostamos porque é bonita não é
uma dedicação por quê Porque é gostoso é
porque é necessário a gente precisa
disso momento em que realizamos a
pesquisa nós não perguntamos diretamente
Quem é a mulher que esse
Já tentaram nem Qual a relação que eles
têm com essa mulher mas eu tenho certeza
que a maioria das pessoas citou alguém
como minha mãe minha irmã minha esposa
enfim a mulher e tudo que a definir
positivamente parece sempre estar
atrelado a outras pessoas é como se a
gente sempre estivesse pertencendo aos
outros e e nunca de nós nunca
pertencemos a nós mesmas mulheres são
sempre dos outros nunca dela mesma delas
mesmas então é um pouco como se o centro
da nossa vida estivesse sempre fora de
Nós quase como se a gente não fosse
Sujeito da nossa própria vida
E então eu queria que a gente repensasse
um pouco o que que é esse perfil que foi
descrito pelos nossos participantes que
geralmente é o perfil que vem a mente de
alguém quando essa pessoa Cita uma
mulher incrível maravilhosa admirável
Então o que é uma mulher carinhosa
atenta inteligente dedicada gente é uma
mulher para casar e aí eu queria
retornar a pergunta que eu fiz no início
O que é uma mulher para fazer ciência
que tipo de perfil é esse será que é
muito diferente do perfil que foi
descrito que foi citado por essas
pessoas será que Aparecido como é bom
acho que a gente precisa voltar um
pouquinho na história para entender um
pouco onde eu quero chegar a ciência
sempre foi produzida por homens mas não
qualquer homem né homens brancos Livres
privilegiados e bem os primórdios da
a moderna funcionava da seguinte forma o
cientista ele ia em praça pública
apresentava a sua hipótese provava a sua
hipótese ele ao vivo para todos então os
cálculos eram desenvolvidos na hora se
fosse algo experimental cientista fazer
ali na hora para que outros cientistas
outros homens brancos livros desejados
questionassem então aquele cientista ele
tinha que está ali recebendo vários
várias críticas de outros homens eram
eram interações muito combativas muito X
então vocês Imaginem um combate verbal
no século 16 era tão agressivo quanto o
combate físico então todos esses homens
ali um combatendo o outro e o cientista
o homem estava ali apresentando essa
hipótese o objetivo dele era não sair
dali derrubado porque assim que a gente
faz ciência não é a gente cria um
paradigma prova Aliás você tem uma
hipótese você desenvolve uma metodologia
para poder provar aquele hipótese e a
partir daí
e essa teoria validada por outros
cientistas até que vem um outro
cientista e derruba essa teoria O
problema é que a gente associa muito a
teoria ao cientista e confunde um pouco
as coisas quando a teoria derrubada
parece que cientista também é derrubado
mas não é bem assim só que toda essa
ideia de combatividade de utilidade de
derrubar o outro foi construída em torno
do perfil do cientista e acabou que isso
esse virou o ideal o que que é um bom
cientista é justamente aquele impositivo
pragmático totalmente dissociado das
suas emoções porque nessa época toda a
gestão emocional toda a gestão da vida
pessoal ficava com a mulher ficava em
casa ou seja o cientista trazia a
público trazia para academia somente
objetividade porque ele não tinha que
lidar com nada do que tava atrás mas a
gente sabe muito bem que não é dessa
forma
o momento que a mulher saiu desses
passos de gerir tudo do pessoal o
cientista teve que lidar com as duas
coisas e as mulheres começaram também a
ingressar na ciência então quando a
gente pára para pensar de fato ciência
objetiva Será que é tão objetivo mesmo a
questão é que a ciência desenvolveu
muito longe da humanidade EA humanidade
historicamente ela foi associada a
figura feminina parece que que existe
uma uma coisa da Separação do sujeito do
objeto ali no cientista e eu tô trazendo
isso não para discutir de fato a
imparcialidade da ciência objetividade
nada disso Na verdade eu quero que a
gente questione os espaços acadêmicos
Nos quais estamos inseridos eu quero que
a gente questione por quê que emoções
sensibilidade empatia flexibilidade por
quê que isso não é muito bem aceito
muito bem recebido não tem muito espaço
para isso para você falar o que você
sente
e para você discutir relações com as
pessoas da academia a relação com seu
orientador por exemplo a uma relação
muito próxima como você vai ter um
relacionamento saudável com seu
orientador se vocês não discutem a
dinâmica da relação de vocês
expectativas enfim Isso precisa ser
endereçado nós somos seres humanos EA
questão toda a questão do porque isso
não tem espaço não é bem recebido é
justamente porque esses atributos de
gerir Emoções geralmente está muito
associada fraquezas a vulnerabilidade e
coincidente mente é associada a figura
feminina
o Ou seja idealmente a mulher para fazer
ciência é aquela que parece com um homem
que se comporta como um homem como o que
é associado à figura masculina Isso
incomoda incomoda a comunidade
científica incomoda mulher e assim você
deve de fato ter um perfil mais próximo
do masculino para conseguir ser
respeitada para conseguir se impor de
alguma forma dentro da ciência mas
também não pode ser muito não pode ser
acima do permitido porque se você
questionar muito se você for uma mulher
muito afetiva muito segura de si
provavelmente Vão te dizer que você é
reativa Vão te dizer que você não aceita
opiniões diferentes da sua se você
reclamar de algum tratamento reclamar de
não ter espaço para expressar o que você
sente vão dizer que você é muito
sensível você toma as coisas muito do
lado pessoal problema é que você fosse
um homem não seria o caso
é uma pessoa reativa como uma mulher uma
mulher assertiva geralmente a vida como
reativa um homem assertivo geralmente a
lido como segura firme então a gente
precisa problematiza essas coisas então
eu queria que a gente ia pensar só
porque que a mulher na ciência a
presença da mulher na ciência seja ela
instrucional moral comportamental por
quê que incomoda tanto incomoda porque
nascença mulher é sujeito ela não tá
mais naquela posição Histórica de
objetificação de Servidão Apesar que a
gente ainda vê muitas situações em que a
mulher é objetificada mas falando um
pouco mais objetivamente a mulher esteve
em várias Exposições históricas da
servidão uma Servidão doméstica sexual
uma atividade de maternal emocional
sempre útil ao outro só que na ciência
não tem filhos não tem marido não tem
gestão do Lar tem você e a sua pesquisa
o foco da sua atenção não são os outros
é você
a pesquisa seu desenvolvimento pessoal
seu desenvolvimento profissional e já
encher Esse é um lugar de protagonismo
tão grande tão importante que nos foi
negado por tanto tempo e que é
majoritariamente ocupado por homens é um
espaço de produção de decisão E é quase
como se a gente tivesse ali tomando um
pouquinho espaço dele sabe e é por isso
que incomoda é por isso que não é bem
recebido então Tecnicamente a mulher
para fazer ciência é aquela que se
afasta do perfil de utilidade isso é bom
isso é bacana
e isso precisa ser naturalizado a gente
está se aproximando do protagonismo bom
trazendo isso de uma perspectiva pessoal
Eu particularmente sou uma pessoa
bastante sensível emotiva Isso fica
muito Claro no meu trabalho nas minhas
relações e o que eu mais ouvi na
academia é isso Você precisa ser mais
forte só não pode se abalar por qualquer
coisa sabe se você não se adaptar você
não vai conseguir academia vai te
destruir vai esmagar se você quiser
continuar na vida acadêmica você tem que
mudar a sua forma de ser a sua forma de
agir a sua forma de pensar e eu ficava
muito com cê nada com aqui o e triste
pensando cara será que meu lugar é na
ciência mesmo Será que eu deveria estar
aqui será que eu não sou muito sensível
para ciência e por que que eu tenho que
me adaptar porque eu tenho que escutar
essas coisas caladas e e tenho que
seguir o baile como todo mundo porque
que a gente não questiona então
e me perguntando porque que a gente
naturalista tanto esse ambiente de
hostilidade essas microagressões que as
vezes nem são tão micro assim tem vários
relatos muito assustadores de
pós-graduandos e a gente vai aceitando
isso vai passando de Cultura para
Cultura a Porque foi assim como
orientador e meu orientador agir assim
comigo então assim com você e por aí vai
bom E por que isso acho que a gente já
sabe a resposta a ciência é um ambiente
uma colonizada e a masculinidade
querendo ou não Ela tá muito atrelada a
brutalidade a distância das emoções
distância da humanidade é o que a gente
chama de masculinidade tóxica que hoje
em dia a gente está conseguindo
trabalhar a mudar essa aos poucos mas
infelizmente essas coisas ainda estão
muito associadas e o que eu quero trazer
aqui é que a gente vê pensa que inclusão
de mulheres não é só em número gente não
adianta colocar um monte de mulher no
espaço e falar pronto
e é democrático e inclusivo porque pro
espaço ser verdadeiramente respectivo
para alguém a pessoa precisa se sente
minimamente confortável àquele espaço ou
precisa parecer minimamente com você é
mais ou menos a dinâmica entre um
morador um visitante Quando você vai
visitar a casa do seu amigo ou da sua
amiga você sabe que você não é um
morador Todos sabem apesar de você estar
ali presente ocupando que eles passam
corpo tanto você quanto seu amigo como
que a gente sabe que ele é um morador e
você não porque é que eles passam tem
fragmentos da personalidade de quem mora
tem fragmentos das decisões é um espaço
onde a pessoa pode fazer o que ela
quiser eu tava curiosa sobre essa essa
dinâmica esse pensamento sobre se sentir
confortável no espaço sentir em casa
então eu perguntei para as minhas
colegas de casa minhas amigas dividem a
casa comigo o que que era
em casa para elas que que era o conceito
de casa e elas me disseram casa para mim
é um lugar que eu fico à vontade que eu
me sinto livre eu sempre quer um refúgio
eu posso fazer o que eu quiser eu entro
no meu quarto o meu quarto tem o meu
cheiro e os móveis Estão dispostos do
jeito que eu gosto e no meu caso eu
gosto de organizar os meus livros de uma
maneira muito particular que eu sei que
só o meu espaço tem só o meu espaço
daquele jeito e a isso eu acho que essa
é a melhor descrição porque a gente
busca dentro da ciência como mulher como
a gente quer se sentir a gente quer
morar na ciência a gente quer se sentir
em casa tanto quanto os homens sentem é
só isso essa é a diferença entre o
morador e um visitante e a gente vai
chegar lá a gente vai chegar no ponto de
morar na ciência porque eu garanto para
você a gente não passou por tudo isso
não chegou até aqui só para visitar
é muito obrigada e